liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wir
begrüßen euch herzlich zum focus wie
lautet der satz heute zum thema werben
mit garten und akkusativ und hier kommt
auch schon die erste aufgabe das subjekt
ist der chef
das verb ist geben das indirekte objekt
ist diese kriterien und das direkte
objekt ist der brief und nun also die
alles entscheidende frage wie lautet der
satz beachte hier dass das indirekte
objekt jeweils im dativ stehen muss und
das direkte objekt im akkusativ also wie
lautet der satz wir sprechen
der chef gibt der sekretärin den brief
sehr gut wir kommen gleich zur zweiten
aufgabe als subjekt ist die mutter das
werbe erzählen indirektes objekt ist die
kinder und direktes objekt ist eine
geschichte beachte auch hier dass das
indirekte objekt im dativ stehen muss
und das direkte objekt im akkusativ wir
kommen zur entscheidenden frage wie
lautet der satz wir sprechen die mutter
erzählt den kindern eine geschichte
die mutter erzählt den kindern eine
geschichte
hast du alles richtig gemacht bravo wir
kommen zur nächsten aufgabe das subjekt
ist ich das verb ist zeigen indirektes
objekt ist der apotheker und direktes
objekt ist das rezept wie lautet der
satz mit dativ und akkusativ wir
sprechen
ich zeige dem apotheker das rezept ich
zeige dem apotheker das rezept war alles
korrekt super wir kommen zur nächsten
aufgabe das subjekt ist der kellner das
verb ist bringen indirektes objekt ist
das paar und direktes objekt ist die
getränke wie lautet der satz wir
sprechen
der kellner bringt dem paar die getränke
war alles richtig
sehr gut dann machen wir gleich mit der
nächsten übung weiter das subjekt ist
die lehrerin das verb ist erklären dass
indirekte objekt ist ich und das direkte
objekt ist die grammatik wie lautet der
satz wir sprechen die lehrerin erklärt
mir die gramm
die lehrerin erklärt mir die grammatik
hast du alles richtig gemacht sehr gut
hier kommt die nächste aufgabe das
subjekt ist die mechaniker das verb ist
zeigen indirektes objekt ist direktes
objekt ist das problem wie lautet der
satz wir sprechen die mechaniker zeigen
dir das problem die mechaniker zeigen
dir das problem
hast du alles richtig gemacht na klar
wer gut wir kommen zur nächsten aufgabe
das subjekt ist der großvater das verb
ist kaufen indirektes objekt ist die
enkelin und direktes objekt ist die
süßigkeiten wie lautet der satz wir
sprechen
der großvater kaufte der enkelin die
süßigkeiten der großvater kaufte enkelin
die süßigkeiten schon wieder alles
richtig gemacht
super wir kommen dann bereits zur
letzten aufgabe das subjekt ist der dieb
das verb ist stehlen indirektes objekt
ist der mann und direktes objekt ist der
computer und nun also wieder die
entscheidende frage wie lautet der satz
der dieb
stiehlt
dem mann
den computer
der dieb stiehlt dem man den computer
hast du alles richtig gemacht sehr gut
dann hast du verstanden wie man aus
werben mit dativ und akkusativ sätze
bildet wir hoffen das quiz hat ihm spaß
gemacht und du bist auch nächstes mal
dabei wenn es heißt wie laut ist ersatz
[Musik]